good
morning millennials welcome back to the
morning toast happy tuesday hello jax
how you doing i'm doing pretty well for
a beautiful tuesday here in new york
city and it's fendi skim's launch day so
i yes up in adam since early this
morning waiting with baited breath to
see what i could snag and i got pretty
much what i wanted good kiss
yeah no i got some stuff too i'm not
gonna lie i was a little um
jilted is that the right word by the
prices
yes but had you not
seen them before no no did you yeah oh
no i didn't see and it was just like 2
900 for a jacket like hello the puffer
the puffer um so i didn't get exactly
what i wanted because i'm a reasonable
human being but i still did get stuff
and you know what's so great is that you
can return it i didn't realize that
before i checked out that you can return
stuff i would have bought even more
stuff see if i liked it i didn't realize
that either but now like i had a pit
about like spending so much money before
9 a.m i actually took something out of
my cart and now i'm like i'm a fool yeah
everything everything's sold out it's
all gonna be marked up it was an
investment i played the stock market
this morning and i just didn't have the
heart yeah no and it's like i i can't
imagine that like if i get something and
they don't end up wearing it and the
tags are still on it like it has a
decent value right yeah i stockx here i
come i think so yeah i don't know if
like skims
like cheapens the fendi brand or it
elevates i think the fact that it is a
limited edition thing
i mean fendi puts out clothes all the
time they don't have a drop that sells
out no in 10 minutes literally
everything was like just flying off the
shelves if you were online i hope you
guys got what you wanted but it was
really crazy to see i imagine that the
fenney team is like whoa blown away yeah
they don't sell like this because it's
just so expensive and the fact that it's
so expensive i thought we would have at
least 30 minutes like i didn't think we
would have like classic kylie lip kit
numbers yeah no i was kind of taking my
time me too um and i missed out on one
thing that was in my cart that dropped
out of my car that i was excited about
because it would have looked cute it was
hard to do the shop pregnant because i
wanted to get stuff that i could wear
now no it's also tight and like body con
i know so i just
i like ordered a size up and everything
it'll fit me when i'm not pregnant
hopefully it fits me when i'm pregnant
yeah no it's very exciting congrats to
kim congrats to us for securing the
things we needed to secure
and it's just a gorgeous day it's
tuesday we have deer toasters for you
guys today which is a personal favorite
of mine and millions of toasters um and
yeah how are you doing i'm doing well
you know just chilling it's been a nice
week i feel like yesterday i got so i
finished a book watched a lot of tv
started a new book spent quality time
with bruiseldorf so important so it was
just a really well-rounded day still
enjoying all of my post-birthday sweets
and treats i'm so jealous i gotta come
over you do i have
everything i have like nothing in my
home it's like i have to make a
concerted effort to eat vegetables and
healthy foods because i have so many
sweet treats you're not gonna poop
that's true i'm pretty i'm that's like
not an issue for me you're pretty
regular yeah i don't have to think about
it like my body does what it needs to do
and if it's been a few days i don't even
realize you know yeah
that's totally right you don't have poop
issues no i really don't um
but margo ashtray once told me that like
she poops
every morning like the second she wakes
up and i'm like
that's psychotic that's like really
intimidating
can i tell you that it's been happening
to me recently and it's a delight like a
great way to just like drop off the kids
before you wake up that's really um now
we're just getting to a place so let us
know where i'd like to come in
i would like to come back from this
conversation okay well um we both
watched curb your enthusiasm we did
which by the way i feel like calling it
curb your enthusiasm is like so weird
because it's called curb
sure no like like i just feel weird
saying curb your enthusiasm it's like
not the name of the show okay so say
herb yeah i was just pointing out that i
said it weird okay um and i thought it
was good
i thought it was so good it was like
giving me old-school curb vibes and the
quandaries that larry found himself in
were very real the middling in the table
was hysterical yes and it's a really
really true point like only true
charismatic gals such as ourselves can
really sit in the middle of a dinner
party at a dinner table of a dinner
party i don't go to that many dinner
parties where it's like a mixture of
people where the conversation needs to
be finessed like that so i actually
don't know if i'm the girl to middle i
don't think i am i think i'm you know a
side just chiming in but i'm not the
person that's gonna like
conduct conversation well the thing is
like i
am a great middle
but
i don't want to be do you know what i
mean so like i could see a dinner party
that i could like finesse fabulously
into the middle but like i will be
selfish and take my talents to the
corner
yeah just because i want to do it on my
terms i'm not working here tonight you
know but i could do it if i needed to
like that's what we do on the show we
make conversation we have
thought-provoking discussions i have it
in me that's just not what i want to do
in my spare time 100
you know however that but would you
rather than have someone else in the
middle and then you're at a boring
dinner party knowing that you have so
much to give you could spice this thing
up yeah and then you're just a
like these are the consequences of your
own actions at that point like you did
middle and now you're paying the price
yeah
so it's it's tough you get in what you
put out and it was a good episode like
i've i felt like the first two episodes
of the season were actually like some of
the worst ever um and this one was good
like i chuckled a bunch me too i
chuckled a bunch and the setups were
there weren't too many things happening
yeah all good i'm feeling good yeah i
just um
i'm still like yearning for a
curb that
commentates on like what's currently
going on in the world or what was going
on in the world when they were filming
and like so as good as this episode
could have been like it's not what it
needed to be still understood but we're
going to have to
change levels i just keep like waiting
for like the other shoe to drop
it's over it's over yeah no it's not
happening that's crazy to me yeah
devastating devastating i also so i was
reading this book called the last thing
he told me by laura dave i think it was
a reese's book club choice i just
finished it yesterday and it was pretty
good in case anybody was thinking about
reading it's like everywhere you know
it's like a super popular book but it
just wasn't
it didn't do much for me but it was a
pleasant read like i was
hopping along
and then i started um
a new book that actually lauren bostic
recommended to us when we were on her
podcast good morning monster yeah yeah
so it's non-fiction and it's about uh
fiction is not real non-fiction is real
i'll never understand okay fiction is
like you know novel
made-up literally new york times
best-selling author and like i can't
figure it out i don't even know what i
tried to find myself in the new york
times was selling this like i didn't
know which list i was like nonfiction or
fiction you are non-fiction
mostly what we read is fiction colleen
hoover yeah yeah yeah like fake stories
so i have had this like wanting to read
for a while i just like was like this is
an interesting choice it's a therapist
who's sharing the stories of five of the
most memorable patients she ever had so
last night i finished the first patient
and it's a great story it's like really
getting me into like a
psycho
therapist analysis by but it's good it's
definitely expanding my mind that's good
yeah so it's a good recommendation
speaking of reese's book club yesterday
i actually found myself on like a rabbit
hole of reese witherspoon's instagram
and i guess it just like never occurred
to me like how rich she is like she does
the most first of all just being like
reese witherspoon all the movies all the
tv shows the morning show
her best work is like these days like
she's not even close to being done big
little eyes but then there's reese's
book club which like has so many
followers i was just like looking into
it because i think i was looking at the
redheads remember i was telling you how
the redheads instagram was so impressive
so i went on like a book club rabbit
hole and then i got to recently then i
got to her draper james like she's just
busy and rich and hello sunshine and
that's probably the biggest of them all
and that's the one that was
like blackstone just
which which one of her projects just
literally got valued at a billion
dollars or got purchased for a billion
dollars hello sunshine probably that's
like the the umbrella right it is it's
and i think it's also the biggest
endeavor of hers it's like the tv
network morning show is hello sunshine
little fires everywhere was hello
sometimes so like she her production
these books and then she makes them into
shows no it's synergy it's it's really
so smart and she's so good at it and
she's really cornered the market on
books and it's like she's done this huge
business empire thing but she's also
still acting in some of the best work
most critically acclaimed still being
nominated for awards like but it's also
like the things that she's working on in
and on are hello sunshine
so it's just all going back in teresa's
pocket synergy it's it's honestly
brilliant yeah no she's
she's doing her thing and then there's
the draper james of it all which
personally isn't for me
but people are obsessed it's like a
southern vibe clothing line yeah not
from i've never shopped it
good for reese it was just like crazy
like she's like one of the richest
celebrities like and she's just like so
underrated no she's so influential yes
like if if she puts her thing on your
book it's like over for you oh that for
sure but like she
like must be so nice to like pick up a
book be like this would make a great
movie and go make it no and then like
it'd actually be good yeah and she's
also doing where the crawdad sing movie
of course she is and that is just like
the biggest book of the last three years
it's crazy like a second yes
second biggest book thank you so much
available at girlfriendjob.com
book also if you head over to that
website you can take it to my tour it's
like loki really soon and like i've i've
had like consistent nightmares about it
for like the past two weeks that's how i
know it's getting really close also you
just like
popped up one day and added a show in
new york city didn't tell your sisters
you didn't tell anyone well so i added
two shows in new york i like to get
started in new york i'm doing them at
city winery i really opened it up only
to the patreon members um
because i like to warm up in front of a
small crowd in front of like people the
like the patreon members are just like
my family so like it'll be it's
basically a friends and family show
they're two really small shows they're
only about 100 people each um at city
winery at the end of this month like
they're really soon i when i first of
all i didn't know about it until they
sold out and people were like can
someone sell me your new york city
tickets i was like girl where have you
been there is no new york city show i'm
like where have i been right then i was
like oh she finally out of new york i i
guess that's like
at the end of the tour so i was like
maybe it's 20 22 and then i realized no
no it's in two weeks yes no it's not
like it's really just you know i
understand what it needs to get
comfortable i understand i'm so excited
for you um i understand what it is now i
just had no idea do you want to know why
you're just like dropping drop and
dropping i don't know why like i feel
like in the past and like up until
recently like every time i farted i
would like put it in our group chat yes
and i just feel like people were getting
like annoyed with my updates so i just
stopped you know okay so here like why
does it have to be all or nothing it's
not like every fart or no update no now
i feel like i'm putting in like just
like the like the sharks
okay like the major life-changing farts
not like the
i'm doing a 100-person show like no one
cares no but we we care because it's new
york but but like you'll be there but
like here's the thing just
it's okay you can share no no it's fine
i'll stop bothering everyone with my
major success like it's definitely
annoying i could totally understand so
then don't come at me like you didn't
tell me like sorry you were not loving
like the updates when i was giving them
so i just stopped giving them who came
at you was that mentioned towards me you
right now no i was just explaining the
journey that i went on and i was excited
for you i was explaining like how i've
been you know
put down by my family
you know it was just like a small thing
it's gonna be fun and light and fun and
city winery i've actually never been to
oh actually we have oh were you there
yet i wasn't there when you were there
but i've been there gorgeous venue
waterfront waterfront it's gonna be like
so intimate i made the room really small
i just wanted to like
go through my material
launch a show in like a warm temperature
yeah temperature practice some new jokes
and it's gonna be super fun that's
awesome i'm happy for everyone who got
tickets um
it was just a surprise for all of us i
guess well don't worry like i care about
you so i got you a ticket we were all
really surprised no for sure i guess i
really did forget to tell you guys but
like it was too in my mind just like not
important no i like i forgot to tell
people important stuff all the time yeah
don't hold it against me it happens to
me in ben all the time it happens to me
in fact that's what i'm talking about i
think it's because like you're like my
husband in a lot of ways like and so i
don't know like something major will
happen and i'll let i'll literally guess
i bet i'm like no i told you no this is
why we don't tell our husbands and i've
thought about it but it's hard they
still zach won't accept this answer but
when i first hear about something that
would be like an amazing opportunity for
us when it first comes across my desk
i'm not telling anyone we're not telling
people about it because it hasn't
happened yet right so then by the time
it actually is happening
you forgot it's not new to us it's not
like oh i need to tell you this thing
but if i told you about every maybe
exciting thing that happened you'd be
disappointed as often as i am so and
also you can't tell someone something
exciting and big before it happens
because otherwise you'll jinx it daddy
that's a brilliant assessment so by the
time it happens it's old news to me
right no that's true so that's why you
don't tell him i forget to tell ben's
like major things all the time
or like if i'm going somewhere like
literally on my way in the airport i'm
like where are you going i'm like i told
you i'm going to coachella like you know
oh that's a little crazy i know
but no that's the reason why yeah
there's never a moment where it's like
okay it's safe to tell people and we're
this is still new to us yeah
so true it's like where have you been
that was six months ago we found it out
keep up
[Laughter]
um so yeah
tour kicks off soon tickets available
girls job dot com tour i have to say
pretty much all my shows are like
sold out or like they're eight months
away like they will be sold out except
for
detroit so i just really need the
detroit toasters i chose detroit
hand-picked detroit because the last
time i was there they put me at this
enormous venue and i'm like guys what
are you doing they're like just trust us
and i did trust them and it sold out
immediately it was one of my biggest
shows on the last tour which is so
random so i'm like i've got to show love
to my detroit sirs
detrosters oh that's good and literally
like i need you guys to sell the show
out or just like buy some tickets okay
detroit or girls.com if you haven't
gotten a ticket to a tour and like you
want to see some friends maybe like a
weekend in detroit
make it a weekend you know the last time
i was in detroit i stayed at this
sickening casino called
motorcity casino it's like a gorgeous
affair like spend the weekend there cool
that sounds fun um but other than that
i'm all set i'm all set we can jump
right in we have some good stories today
we have dear toasters so let's just
without further ado
head into the fast life stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
i just want to say we're like now at
that period in life where it's [ __ ]
hot in the studio because it's like cold
outside so the heat is on in here and
i'm gonna be start showing up in
t-shirts and i don't want to hear from
anyone okay okay just wanna let you know
the heat is not on it is so [ __ ] hot
in here i felt this way yesterday i
think what it is is it's
nice outside it's like 50 degrees
according to weather snitch there's no
heat or ac on i'm hot so you're just
like in a room i'm like sticky and i'm
not happy about it i'm sorry i'm
actually perfectly comfortable but you
know what i am happy about you look
perfectly comfortable what's up from the
cotton commercials where yes
that's such a specific reference
i thought that was like an iconic
legally blonde moment you know
the cotton commercial okay
you really have been
like staying at home a lot watching tv
um today's episode is brought to you by
public wreck we all settle for
traditional retail sizes but why what
does a medium person look like how can
two people wear medium when they're
completely different heights pants are
made to fit one type of body and
everyone else has to settle for a less
than perfect fit well that's why you've
gotta check out public wreck they make
athleisure in waist and in seam sizes
because they believe comfort
starts with a better fit their all day
jogger is a first of its kind technical
pant available in waist and in seam
sizes this means women can shop based on
their unique proportions no more
settling for small medium or large
they are perfect pants for working out
going out they're highly versatile and
they've got you covered whatever life
has to throw at you they have 30
combination sizes and four different
length options so their joggers will fit
your body perfectly in all the right
places i've always thought as like a big
person with short legs it's so unfair
like how they make stuff and the fact
that every single place on earth doesn't
give you an option for length is so
unfair and that's why public wreck like
they're the best leggings because i
usually get like bunches at the bottom
of my ankles and they leave like prints
on my ankles because i have so much
extra material because i'm so short but
not with the uh public rack ones you can
literally measure from top to bottom
it's amazing you choose like your size
of yourself and then your inseam length
and they're literally like custom-made
and they don't only sell joggers they
got t-shirts sweatshirts jackets all
that are super comfortable um we've
never had pants that fits so well it's
really a game changing website check out
public wreck they really do discounts
but right now we have an exclusive offer
just for the toast listeners go to
publicrec.com and use the code toast for
ten percent off that's publicrec rec dot
com promo code toast for 10 off
okay our first story heartbroken kim
kardashian addresses astroworld tragedy
on instagram as did kendall and there
was a repost from chloe kim has weighed
in on the deaths that took place at
travis scott's asher world concert
festival on friday she said absolutely
heartbroken for the lives who were lost
and anyone who was hurt at astroworld
just like all of you our family is in
shock by the tragedy we are keeping all
of the victims families and loved ones
impacted in our prayers for healing as
well as travis who we know cares so much
about his fans and is truly devastated
so chloe reposted that statement and
then kendall put out a statement of her
own as did drake as you drake yes yeah i
find it interesting that like
people like and we spoke about this
yesterday people
are really looking at the kardashians
here like keeping a microscope on them
like seeing what they'll do and feeling
like they're partially to blame which i
just don't agree with well yeah and i
think there's a difference between like
kylie and kendall's response because
they were there versus the rest of the
family was in la celebrating chris's
birthday right and i think for a lot of
people it was in their minds like a
little out of touch for them to be like
posting all these videos all weekend
like flowers while all of this was going
down so i am glad that they released a
statement but again it's not
it's i mean it's just a sad thing that
happened in general to the world like we
should all be talking about it we should
all be like
thinking about it so i think like
them releasing a statement is great but
again i think people are just like
really wanting to hear from kylie yeah
and i i this and it it was nice that
they shared and i'm sure it's affected
their their whole family because it's
affected kylie and you know they're all
one big unit um
but again i mean people who are waiting
to hear from the kardashians and like on
this it's like it's a little far removed
yeah no i think so too honestly i was
curious to hear what drake was going to
say because drake was there and the the
climax of the show was when drake came
out and drake did release something i
think yesterday or last night um
just kind of saying how he hates putting
things on instagram but like that's the
way
and he's just like praying and
and i just think um
i don't know i don't know where we go
from here i don't know like where where
who we're blaming what's going on but i
actually did hear something interesting
about the whole ticket refund oh what
did you hear and like there are people
like lawyers are warning certain people
maybe not to accept the refund because
if you read the terms and conditions
you're like agreeing to not litigate or
not sue
so just like to be really careful of
accepting the refund oh that's
interesting a lot of um of the
concert goers have already started the
lawsuit process they're like two big
lawyers in houston who are representing
a lot of different people also i saw
yesterday travis is partnering with
betterhelp to get like mental health
services for the people who experience
who experience it because like not only
were there the physical injuries
hundreds of them but so many people saw
terrible things bodies like awful awful
things and even to just
that even if you didn't see that stuff
and just knowing that you were at a
concert where yeah it's
it's very taxing it's a lot to process
yeah so he is um trying to help people
get that sort of help okay i actually
think that's good
um
yeah it's just like the
like the conversations people are having
and just like what's been going on it's
really i just can't get over how like
crazy it is that this whole thing
happened in general yeah and then i'm
sure you saw yesterday but um one of the
people who is critically injured in a
coma was a nine-year-old boy yes i did
and i saw a picture of him and he was
really cute and it's so sad it's so sad
and did they identify that person i
didn't see it but i i really hope so
that's such a terrible way to find out
that like your son or your brother
passed away yeah
it's just
everything that keeps coming out about
this story is more horrible than the
next and i just think people are really
angry and they're looking for a place to
direct their anger and like i understand
that i do yeah and i think that there's
a lot of places where anger needs to be
directed because it's like a uh
it was just a storm of a lot of
different ingredients that need to be
looked at going forward and just as
a society yeah you know
it's i just i like i still can't believe
that this happened and it's just it's
the craziest thing and i know i keep
saying that but it's like the only thing
it's just insane yeah and i just feel
really sad so i hope
everything i hope everyone who sues gets
what they need like for real yeah agreed
okay our next story switching gears jeff
bezos tweets um leonardo dicaprio a
titanic-sized threat after girlfriend
lauren sanchez swoons over the actor
okay this is actually funny
so as you guys probably saw this video
it's on our instagram so go watch it if
you haven't yet of jeff bezos and lauren
sanchez meeting leo at the lacma art and
film gala in la and lauren is all about
leo yeah it's a really interesting video
um just like reading the body language
it's just so interesting like leo can't
get away from lauren fast enough lauren
is like licking her lips like nestling
in his armpit it's giving ramona
it's giving ramona singer yes that's
like if you guys watch roni like imagine
you know how she flirts so is harry
dubin lauren is ramona and it's the eyes
and it's the like jackie that is so
[ __ ] true
literally
so the internet was obviously uh you
know
ablaze with this video uh barstool
posted leo is mr steal your girl and
then jeff bezos wrote on monday he
posted a picture
leaning over a sign that says danger
step
steep cliff
fatal drop and he said leo come over
here i want to show you something
it's actually a really funny response
that is so funny that you find it so
funny oh you know what like that he
gotta laugh out loud from you because i
mean i've seen this a hundred times and
like i was like oh he's like a whitney
but then somewhat sometimes like the way
you read it just made me laugh yeah i
mean you know what
jeff bezos like i don't know him at all
no like every time you know like
every time
his personality comes through i'm just
like who is this man like what is this
when you saw him laughing like before he
went to space he was like
when he was wearing cowboy boots with
his
spacesuit like i just every time he does
something it's so
radically different from like who i
thought he would be
and this is just another iteration of
that i love people who can laugh at
themselves and who can like get in on
the joke and are good sports and to me
this is like the perfect example of it
like literally his girlfriend is like
drooling over leonardo dicaprio like he
makes a joke about it because like even
if you're the richest man in the world
like leonardo dicaprio i was leonardo
dicaprio and i just thought this was
like you know what i actually i really
like this response you respect it i do
yeah i do i do too like everyone was
laughing at him and they're laughing
with him yeah because otherwise that
video was just sad yikes yikes bikes
like it was painful but knowing like he
thinks it's funny like yeah of course
like i'm the richest man in the world
and even i can't keep a woman away from
leonard like that's funny yeah i agree
and i really have respect for this
response like it's funny
that's okay cool yeah and like some good
news for you
when you're a billionaire like you don't
have to respond to like moronic internet
viral
content culture but he did and it was
funny and he he came out on top yeah do
you think now that i've been watching
succession and like
watching kendall roy try and like get
fire tweets out you know that's like
part of his um it's so sad strategy like
hiring all these people to write like
cool takes yeah um do you think that he
had like a team of people
who submitted responses to him and he
chose it's possible when you're that
rich but it's really giving me like dad
humor like like organic yeah like he had
the picture in his phone he's like
waiting to use it like i don't think he
took that picture today it's like from
you know one of him and lauren's trips
yeah
and you know what this whole thing just
reminded me that him and lauren are
still together
i know like they were such big news
national inquirer i want to get drunk
with you not too drunk read the
newspaper in the morning his texts were
leaked it was so embarrassing and then
they kind of like disappeared so i'm
like well did that whole scandal break
them or are they still together and i
just never really followed up on it but
now i know for sure that they are still
together and i went
this whole
moment caused me to go find her
instagram and it's so interesting i've
been there before it's so
like it's giving trophy wife it is and
it's amazing yeah no they're kind of
cute yeah
i know i'm like not entirely not here
for it you know yeah no and the proof is
in the pudding as we always say it's
been a long time because we reported on
those texts like in the old old studio
yeah so it's like two years at least and
i i want to get drunk with you but not
too drunk oh no no i just want to wake
up and read the newspaper with you oh no
no one like now that i'm like getting to
know jeff and i read those texts like
it's kind of sweet
yeah no jeff do your thing don't let the
haters stop you don't let the haters
stop you yes but do you also think he's
like
encroaching on elon musk's vibe a little
bit like
quirky funny guy no because elon has
like a very
definite like
personality like we know elon 100
jeff bezos is kind of like the gift that
keeps on giving like we never know what
we're gonna get it's like a box of
chocolates i feel like if it wasn't for
elon he wouldn't lean into this side of
himself obviously elon's had so much
success he wants to be like the affable
billionaire yeah and he's not gonna
because like we can smell his
desperation from new york but we do
appreciate the effort yeah and it's
they're landing these things are landing
so it's going well so now i'm thinking
like maybe he does have a team of people
writing tweets for him i do think that
he does and i think that he's always you
know one step behind elon yeah
whereas like no one has the keys to
elon's twitter like it's all elon no one
is giving elon cool takes your twitter
yeah yeah
are you ready for our next story
yeah carol baskin says she joined enough
no no but i thought this story was
interesting can you just can you just
give it a minute
carol baskin says she joined a secret
support group for traumatized
celebrities oh i haven't been invited
carol baskin who was accused in the 2020
documentary series of having murdered
her husband and fed his body to exotic
cats claims that there is a secret
support group for a-listers traumatized
by the trials of fame and she said she's
being kicked out now for telling people
yeah or maybe she like stopped attending
she said that she was invited to join it
after the tiger king phenomenon made her
into a public pariah she said on a
podcast that as the netflix show was
becoming a smash hit and she was turning
into a household name somebody reached
out to her and said quote i have this
group of celebrities and we meet or
before kovid we would meet i forget what
day it was that they met each week but
they would meet once a week and they'd
all get together and they'd talk about
what it was like to live their lives she
said and i can see why now why
celebrities run around in dark glasses
and scarves and ducking like they're
running from the law from one place to
another because it's just it's
overwhelming to just be constantly
surrounded by people she wouldn't say
who the members of the group were but
she said there were 21 or 22 people and
that there were only three or four
people in the group that she didn't
recognize and that was only because they
were sports personalities and she's not
she doesn't keep up with athletes okay
you know what like this does sound like
something that would exist i don't know
if like if it's actually that cool would
they actually invite carol baskin but it
does kind of
bring something up like about karabakh
and i know you didn't watch tiger king
but like homegirl was villainized when
at the end of the day there's literally
no actual proof or evidence police-wise
that she killed her husband and two like
at the end of the day she was the only
person in that documentary who gave a
[ __ ] about the tigers like she was the
one running a sanctuary the others were
the ones like keeping them in cages like
stealing their sperm to like make more
so like loki
we're all like joe exotica like it's
actually a really unethical story like
joe exotic did not care about the
animals like he kept them in zoos
whereas carol was rescuing and taking
care of all the animals that these
morons like joe exotic were doing
bringing them over from like africa so
yeah they made her into a murderer when
loki she didn't murder anyone allegedly
there's no proof yeah it she could have
but there's no proof but it's
circumspect right so like there's no
proof that she so she really did get
like the short end of the stick and she
like got turned into a joke i remember
that prankster who like thought she was
gonna she thought she was gonna be on
jimmy fallon these youtubers pranked her
into thinking like she was like a
national joke and like i do feel bad for
her when like low-key she just cares
about the animals yeah so the fact that
this group could exist like does make
sense to me and now i'm dying to be
invited yeah like who else do you think
what's the criteria because i'll
i'll expose myself a little bit like get
another cancellation just to be invited
yeah it's like crazy it's like if it's
a-listers would they really reach out to
like someone going through it i guess
tiger king was the biggest show it was a
year so that would make carol bastian an
a-lister
no but it would make her like a a
momentary
disaster yeah and maybe like if the
people in the group you know they saw
what she was going through they were
like let's have her in yeah that's so
interesting
because like the thing is when you ask
pretty much anyone in hollywood i was
just reading um
a tweet but dakota johnson did an
interview and she was asked or she spoke
about how like she's worked with a lot
of people
who have been canceled and they were
naming like army hammer and
i saw casey affleck i think okay and she
was just like cancer culture
like people in hollywood like do not
subscribe to like cancellations even
though like you think that they would
yes and no because i do feel like maybe
in their hearts it's like
they might not cut this person out of
their life but then they go public and
they're like i don't agree right what so
and so did and like they've just got to
throw each other under the bus yeah like
the industry just calls for whenever any
person in hollywood is asked about like
cancellations and just cancel culture in
general they're like vehemently against
right of course you won't hear anyone
say like i am for the cancellations but
then like you everyone's like i'm
against cancer culture but yeah totally
but what but i would just love to know
who's in this group like if it's in fact
true and it is in fact a-list
yeah no it definitely gives you
something to think about but if it's a
secret society like and she's talking
about on a podcast the first rule of
fight club is don't talk about fight
club so yeah no she probably won't be
invited back yeah but like she didn't
know you know
no i think she probably did but maybe
she stopped going maybe she's healed
yeah i i hope so i really i wish
healing i will pray for her i really
will yeah it just makes you think about
it in a different way doesn't it it does
and you know what like those stupid
documentaries like about nothing like
they just take a side you know and this
documentary was like so clearly
anti-carol baskin but you know what
carol baskin in my eyes and in the eyes
of the law has done nothing wrong yet so
let's just keep that in mind thank you
claudium are you ready for our next
story only if it's brought to you by
home medics i know you're obsessed
jackie i am homedics is a new sponsor
and they sent us these products that
just it felt like christmas morning and
like santa knew exactly what i needed
and wanted because they are like a home
massage spa
everything so they have like this foot
massager which my feet have been killing
me that you just put your little
feetsies in there you can get the
massage turn on heat turn on air
pressure it's amazing it's like remote
control i'll just sit there with brew
and we're like z
as we get older everything is getting
sore and we just don't recover like we
used to so that's why why you've got to
check out home medics they've got a
whole line of massage products from a
massage gun with built-in hot and cold
technology to a massage cushion that
lets you lie down or sit up depending on
your therapeutic needs to a three in one
foot massager with vibration so powerful
it loosens the muscles in your legs and
lower back their massagers will address
all your pain points from head to toe so
yes we tried the massage cushion and was
uh the foot massager the foot massage is
just a great thing to leave it by your
couch like whenever you're watching tv
whether you're cold you're hot it's
fabulous like we're on our feet all day
like we deserve to relax yeah you guys
this has been a game changer for me
really my feet at my back they're shot
yeah for you especially and the cushion
and the massager it's like having one of
those amazing massage
places in your house
whether you're dealing with chronic pain
or just looking to help your muscles
recover from a workout we've got good
news right now if you go to
homemedics.com slash toast use the promo
code toast you'll receive a free
portable phone sanitizer when you buy a
hundred dollars or more in massage
products and that's a 60 value so that's
h o m e d i c s dot com slash toast use
the promo code toast for your free
portable phone sanitizer with 100
massager purchase that's a great gift
with purchase that phone sanitizer your
husband's obsessed with his yeah also
just a great gift for anyone as we
approach gifting season and you're
trying to get creative merry christmas
merry christmas
merry christmas
happy holidays
is that the backstreet boys
in sync yeah same thing our next story
fans are demanding that james corden be
kept out of the wicked movie yes i saw
change.org is quaking aspiring glindas
and alphabets across the nation are
putting their differences aside and
joining forces to ask that james ford
and be kept as far away from oz as
possible a change.org petition demanding
that cordon be left out of universal's
wicked movie launched over the weekend
and has amassed more than 34 000
signatures they say the request is
simple james corden in no way shape or
form should be in or near the production
of the wicked movie that's pretty much
it
okay so i feel two ways about it okay me
too because one
i saw this headline
funny okay i'm laughing sure yeah no and
actually like
james corden like has actually not been
in a successful musical so like for the
sake of the
like the curse i do think he should be
left out but it's also really mean it's
so mean and like why does it have to be
like for like why does someone have to
get so propped up we're all obsessed
with james corden host this host that be
in this be in that and then like we just
decide that it's getting a little much
for us when we're the ones who we're
consuming over exposure
karaoke and then it has to be a
change.org petition yeah no this is like
a the cycle of like of celebrity fandom
and how toxic it is giving anne hathaway
it's giving anne hathaway a hundred
percent and it's just the way we treat
it and wasn't right back then no you're
right and she has [ __ ] trauma
we need to learn from that no you're 100
right but like also i don't want him in
the movie so like what do we do about
that no i'm being dead serious like
yeah but maybe that's just because i've
been conditioned to find him annoying
because like
partially because he is annoying and
partially because like people just are
like how annoying is this video of james
corden i'm like yeah i guess it is
annoying i don't but if you followed
anyone around and like videoed the
annoying things that they did like my
god anyone would become hated yes i
agree it's just really mean like this is
just like mean
like james's feelings
no and it's just we need to do better
like when it's a it's a cycle you know i
i so
i understand why james has never hurt
anyone i understand why people wouldn't
want james
in the movie not only do i understand i
support it
but this is wrong i agree it's really
mean like he's not a bad person no he's
not and he's just like a musical fanatic
yeah and he actually he's like a good
singer but he does like really crazy
stuff like
now i'm thinking about like when they
were promoting cinderella yes and the
video of him pumping his crotch at the
car yeah i know i saw i literally saw
yesterday on tick tock
and i think like it's but so maybe this
is a moment for james to reflect yeah
and be like okay why am i the way that i
am no like
there's things that are good like the
carpool karaoke is good like him on that
plane with kanye
so we need to make a pros and cons list
of james's work yeah and we need to
start trimming away the things
that are rubbing people spill your guts
is good
yes yeah except i actually did see there
was a petition about that too because
it's like insensitive because a lot of
those are like cultural foods and like
you're calling them gross so maybe you
just need to switch up the foods but i
think conceptually it's a good good way
to get celebrities to spill tea yeah i
think as a late late night host he's
good i think his show is like popular
yeah celebrities love him i would keep
that in the pros column ari loves him
that's the thing yeah no and he has
access to all these celebrities because
they just like love him as a person yeah
him and he went on a vacation with harry
styles and adele yeah
and everyone was tagging me he gave
adele a piece of gum that was chewed
by celine diana yes it was in her 73
questions yes yes
okay so those are the pros and i think
that's really good and he's also good at
hosting award shows very good you know
cons obviously are stopping the music
stopping the streets and doing music and
you know what i think i've just kind of
put it together because you just made a
really good point like
he really thrives and this is him as
just being a good host he thrives in
environments that are not about him like
he's interviewing celebrities he's
giving other people awards where it gets
muddy is when he is becoming like the
star like in cats like
that's where it gets difficult because
he's like more of like a background
he's perfect as a background piece but
then when he becomes a star in certain
movies and musicals that's where it gets
dicey in my opinion but i just feel like
cats was doomed with her exactly with or
without james gordon yeah i see like
people weren't annoyed that he was in
the friends reunion but he was actually
excellent he didn't insert himself too
much it was about the six characters i
thought he was very good in that
yeah and what he did in cinderella was
wrong i agree was very wrong he made it
all about him wait was he in cinderella
he was in cinderella he played one of
the mice that turns into
uh a foot man
and when they became footmen like they
literally had 10 minutes worth of scenes
jackie i of them figuring out like oh
how do i pee jackie this is so random
but we have to just i have to tell you
something and then we'll go back to
talking about this you just reminded me
of it okay you said foot man okay at the
potomac reunion i believe it was ashley
darby who said i put my foot in it i
know jackie she quoted you via the proud
family mm-hmm okay i just had to i was
wanting to she's quoting sugar mama i
believe i believe too she put what was
she talking about
the coffee and
music video yes coffee and
coffee and love maybe yes she put her
foot in it okay thank you back to james
corden so yes i did not know he was in
cinderella
if you saw i thought he was just helping
her promote it in that vile way no he
was
he was in it too okay so yeah i think
we've actually cracked the james corden
code once again free ideas here for
james corden and his team i think that
him wanting to go beyond his abilities
like as a host are what's rubbing people
the wrong way no and like hollywood just
has this problem where like something's
working okay we're going to throw it at
everything and it's like we are fatigued
and you're ruining james corden he's a
talented man we've liked him for so long
you've got to pull back the range that's
so true they literally like find
something that people like like
americans and they just like shove that
person down our throats right megan
trainer right and so it's gotta stop but
a change.org position like is a little
mean it's extra
it's too much no and i think that like
we operate in this world where like we
think celebrities don't have feelings
but like what if james literally read
that like he did that would hurt his
feelings he definitely read it yeah i
think it's mean i think he may be
laughed though yeah i don't know if he's
in on the joke he should get in on the
joke i think that's actually would be a
great way for him to get out of this rut
he's currently in like but i could see
him like in on the joke and then like
going home and crying himself to sleep
100
he's a sensitive man he's british like i
i completely agree yeah but i just think
for his image like if he got in on the
joke and started doing like stories on
late night about like the petition like
people would respect him much like jeff
bezos yeah he should do a story about
the petition um
i just
we need there needs to be a line you
guys yeah and it was crossed 100 i do
think but i fully support the message of
the petition
he could have a little part no there's
no such thing as a little part for james
gordon no when you're james corden there
are no small parts
he's going to make it just small actors
he's going to make it a big part 100 oh
my god but i could totally see him being
like the lion
lion because it's like wizard of oz
there's a lion in wicked i'm pretty sure
uh maybe not i heard that he had already
been cast but i heard that prematurely
as doctor
like the professor
interesting i
yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is some content news that i
find to be exciting
it's the final story
[Music]
corden please don't cry
it's beautiful
okay our fifth and final story is some
exciting news amazon is launching a new
series called the ferragnez starring
kiara ferragni and fedez and their whole
family you're kidding not kidding they
are
prime videos
newest reality tv family that's fabulous
the show will premiere in december it
filmed throughout your wedding no no
it filmed throughout late 2020 and early
2021 while she was pregnant while fidez
is preparing for uh music festivals
no kiara ferrari was like the og passion
blogger she turned her brand into like a
billion dollar business she's the most
iconic fashion influencer i don't even
think she's an influencer anymore like
she used to be the blonde salad remember
like she still does influence her tings
um but she's also so rich but she's also
just like the face of louis vuitton
right like she's just a celebrity and
she's and she's italian and she married
an italian pop star fedez and they are
just like the biggest thing in milan did
a baby their wedding was like literally
a carnival it was crazy she has two
sisters who are also influencers and the
whole family is it's keeping up with the
fragments
is
uh frogme and fedes their names put
together that was their their writing
hashtag
so that's the name of the show because
it's you know about their family which
is i think this is going to be amazing
no i think this is groundbreaking like
honestly amazon has been really slacking
in their content recently like i don't
remember anything
like when we watch viral shows like that
everyone's watching none of it has been
on amazon in a really long time like
they needed this win and it's i'm so
gonna watch us yeah also her she had a
documentary a few years ago yeah that is
also on prime video it was like kiara
rogni unposted and that was pretty good
so i think this is just going to be
great i feel like she's had i mean every
year is so busy for her but especially
in the last year like she gave birth so
it's going to be chronicling chronicling
her pregnancy but like she never slowed
down for one [ __ ] second no she's
iconic she's iconic she has amazing
style she has like access to like
every designer people places things in
the world i think this is gonna be an
amazing show and for the promo shoot
dave la chappelle shot the art in front
of the duomo in milan like
just sickening that is second and this
is just no the duomo is in florence
oh yeah i've actually been that is true
that's what i meant because um i know
that from the medici oh i know it
because i've been there and i
didn't climb the stairs because it was
so hot and i like left my friends
halfway oh and i got gelato um this is a
great idea i'm very excited i'm
definitely gonna be watching it and i
just wanna like really i'm so curious
about her business like that's what i
would love to know more about like
what does she do like how does she make
money like everything i mean i how does
she not make money yeah and also so she
has a brand which like a lot of
influencers and celebs have brands but
like her [ __ ] is so cute yeah like the
eyes the shoes so
so cute yeah i think i used to have a
pair of her loafers yeah and she
actually just came out with a line of
jewelry that was soaking all sold out
but it was sickening stuff and she's
just like the true definition of like a
global lifestyle brand like she's
literally global she is an international
lifestyle
beauty fashion brand yeah it's gonna be
a really good show yeah so i'm excited
about that um okay well those were the
past five feel so you needed to know
them and we're not even close to being
done because it's your toasters which is
brought to you by the pill club life is
stressful enough access to health care
shouldn't be luckily getting birth
control is one less thing you have to
worry about with the pill club you'll
never
have to make a trip to the doctor or
wait in line at the pharmacy ever again
they provide access
they provide access to care for from
comfort from the comfort of your own
home and delivery to your door in
discreet packaging they carry over 120
fda approved brands at the pill club
most brands of birth control are free
with insurance or medicaid otherwise
their prices start super low at just
nine dollars a month with insurance
without insurance excuse me they deliver
birth control to your door for free in
discreet packaging and right now when
you go to the
pillclub.comtoast the pill club is
offering a 10 donation to bedcider.org
for every morning toast listener who
becomes a patient your donation will
help low-income individuals get access
to birth control through bedsider.org so
not only are you saving money on birth
control you don't have to go out to the
doctor it's all getting delivered you're
also helping people in need get access
to birth control so that's the pill
club.com toast to get your first birth
control care package and donate to help
more women in need
of affordable birth control remember
that's the pill club.com toast and you
have to use that link if you want the
donation to go through great okay dear
toasters our advice segment we do every
tuesday here at the morning toast if you
ever want to email us your submission
it's dear toasters gmail.com you can
change people's names we will always
keep you anonymous um and just let us
know how you're doing all right first up
hello claudia's jackie theo and bruno
first of all i love you both so much
jackie congrats on the baby and claude
congrats on the tour you guys are my
favorites my best friend and i literally
dressed as you guys for halloween this
year
she said you reposted her oh have fun
okay we got some good costumes this year
i have a close-knit group of i have a
close-knit group of nine girlfriends
from high school most of us live in
different cities now but have been best
friends for about 10 years now we're all
meeting in houston to go to your show
claudia oh yes
the first of us got engaged in september
and immediately led us to know that they
had already booked a baller venue in
houston on the evening of october 1st
2022. it's going to be one of those big
fat greek weddings that i would die if i
missed not to mention we are all
obsessed with her beyonce and love her
family like it's our own
now for the conflict
halloween morning my mom sent a text in
our family group text my only girl
cousin had just gotten engaged i
immediately squealed and sent my cousin
multiple
congratulatory texts
to which she responded make sure you are
free on october 1st october 2022.
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i responded with
oh no one of my best friends is getting
married that day to which she responded
wait is that a joke lol oh god oh my god
she's already a bridezilla my cousin and
i are not super close she estranged
herself from our entire family for about
three years it was truly the strangest
thing but all is well now thankfully she
told me that she is planning a smaller
wedding at our family's lake house about
an hour outside houston i would go if
there wasn't another wedding that day
but it feels strange that i have to
justify going to one wedding over
another on the one hand i don't want to
miss out on being with my family at my
cousin's wedding think of the family
portraits that i won't be in but i would
also
but i would also have the most fomoist
fomo ever if i missed out on my friend's
wedding that same day what should i do i
feel guilty for pulling that i heard
about this wedding first and it's going
to be more fun card but i also know that
the that family's family and i would
hurt
i would be heard if my only girl cousin
didn't come to my wedding whenever that
will be but i also love my friend like
family and would be equally sad if she
wasn't there at my big day either
sincerely help oh i don't [ __ ] know i
don't know like honestly like life is
about doing the things you want to do
and you want to go to your friend's
wedding and i just think you should go i
know that sounds terrible because
it's everything either way someone's
going to be disappointed you're going to
be missing out on something
so just go to the one that you would
rather go to like at least
just there's no right answer and there's
no wrong answer like you can only go to
one just make a choice obviously you
should probably like do the family is
first but like
for some reason it just you didn't sell
it yeah no you didn't sell it at all
like because we're so family like always
like even if it sucks like you go to the
family thing but i don't know i'm just
like not feeling convinced and i think
that you should go to your friend's
wedding
yeah i think you should really look
inward on this one there's no magical
answer how to make everyone happy here
right you can't do both they're an hour
away they're the same day you can't do
both so you really just need to choose
yeah and
whichever one you were to choose like
there's going to be repercussions
repercussions so you just have to make a
choice and you know if you do choose
your friend's wedding like you just need
to know like can you live with that
decision like it'll like you'll always
be gone from the pictures are you i
don't need to know more about
the relationship with this cousin like
you were strange for three years but
like are you guys super close now she
said we're close she says no she said
we're not super close no but she didn't
say super close but she did say things
are good i do think she was trying to
like downplay it so that we would tell
her to go to her friend's wedding
because that's what she wants to hear
she said my cousin and i aren't super
close she estranged herself from our
entire family for about three years
because that's what you want to hear
because that's what you want to do so
just do what you want to do and just
deal with the consequences yeah i think
in like this post-covered world like we
should all just be doing what we want to
do like like short short life's too
short to like miss out on a really fun
wedding
yeah i think it's okay i do but also
because you literally sold it that way
but you have our blessing whatever you
decide to do so just know that and if
your cousin's upset be like the morning
josh told me yeah send her this episode
maybe you shouldn't have estranged
yourself from your family for three
years if you wanted your cousin to come
to your wedding and you can send her
this episode so that she can know what
it feels like because i think all of the
listeners right now don't know what to
say to you and like all the listeners
are conflicted because family is always
fierce but the way you read this email
to us like obviously you should go to
your friend's wedding so like you like
kind of gaslight us all
i don't know i just think that you
should
just make choice stick with it it sucks
regardless but also be fun regardless
yeah but like that's not a helpful piece
of advice she asked for which wedding to
go to and you literally just told her
make a decision
i told i gave her permission to make
whatever decision she wanted yeah that's
what i did yeah and you know what
sometimes all you need is a little
permission
okay next up hello thank you both for
brightening my weekdays here's a little
dating history i've had a couple serious
relationships over three years in my
life and then i was single for four
years where i probably went in about 30
dates some turned semi-serious some
didn't make it past the first date
i've lived in the same city for five
years and absolutely love it my parents
are moving here soon and i have amazing
friends here i've been dating a man for
two years now who was everything i'd
hoped i would find he is my favorite
person in the world but we are long
distance in different states due to his
job and other commitments i only see him
a few times a year my quandary i'm so
freaking lonely sometimes i feel like i
should just date someone in my own city
even though i wasn't able to find anyone
nearly as compatible in the years i was
looking my boyfriend can't move here
because of his work and family and if he
did it would be 10 plus years down the
road me moving there is the most
probable option but i have my family
here for me and i haven't lived near
them since high school plus my friends
are here and i love the city so much
help do i move try it out for a while
and even though
his time is still limited i'd be in a
new city chilling on my own should i try
and find someone in my own city that's
less complicated thank you in advance
for your unfiltered opinions and
thoughtful advice i truly need it xo a
daily toaster i just want to say one
thing before about this girl that's the
only thing that's concerning me is like
kind of the way you're writing this
email
you're like
really analytical like like you're a
data analyst well i did it here and we
had x compatibility and now we have this
man with y compatibility but the
distance is y over x but listen you know
what
i'm not gonna fault you for being a
rational thinker you know you could put
a little more feeling into it yeah it's
like
but some people like lead only with
their feelings and you don't use their
head and that's chaotic and that's
chaotic too like someone who would jump
from like city to city just like so
i i'm not gonna fault you too much but i
agree but my advice would be like put
your heart into it a little bit like if
just the idea of
moving and being with your boyfriend
make you so happy that it can forego the
fact that you're not near your family
anymore or does the idea of going to
find someone new in your own city and
breaking up with your current boyfriend
break your heart i need to know how you
like feel like what do you love more
like your hometown your family your life
or this man
and i'm just not getting any um like
feelings from you i don't know how you
feel do you love this man or just she
said that they're really like that this
is the guy it's giving robot
it is giving rhoda robot but like she's
giving facts you know which is super
super helpful especially in the deer
toasters because we're always like
looking for you know supplementary facts
i mean just the idea of you moving to be
with him like this better be the
greatest love of all time or else you're
setting yourself up for failure no
friends like no family he works all the
time like but if this is your person
your soul mate like you go there and you
start your new life and you start a
family and yeah right you make your own
life like right your kids are you can't
live for your high school friends and
your hometown
but do you love this man that i didn't
gather you love him more than your
hometown it sounds like you ran a
compatibility test like on the internet
when we used to do with your kids like
claudia and maverick 98 compatible yeah
but sometimes i can love you more than
my hometown so true also so and that's
apparently a normal position to have so
yeah i just need more information from
you like from your heart like where is
your heart in this i think you need to
look inward that's two for two i'm
looking inward today
and
put aside the charts and data points
yeah close your laptop
close your laptop
and just ruminate in your feelings close
your laptop close your eyes and open
your heart yeah
i don't know how maybe a drink maybe
could do that yeah you seem like someone
who's not overly emotional which i love
because i think sometimes when people
write us in like they're so led by
emotion and like not rational but i
think actually you your the pendulum has
swung the other way like i could use a
little i love this man something like
some emotion yeah
that's all i need so i don't know but
you can't keep doing like this where
you're like you're lonely because she
but like she she did say that that you
know she's lonely without him
so and that
either you guys have to break up or you
have to move there sorry yeah i agree
the way it's going now it's not gonna
work no it's making me sad okay final
one dear claudia and jackie first time
writer long time toaster here i have a
very complicated family problem that i
would love to get your input on my
family is super close so close that my
sister-in-law has become my absolute
best friend and the sister that i never
had i do have an actual sister but we're
not as close that's so easy
that's so mean that is so mean
um anyways this sister-in-law mary kate
has a twin sister ashley
ashley has also become our adopted
sister-in-law also best friend the three
of us have had babies together got
married together have been through
have been there through
good and bad for each other we celebrate
all holidays and birthdays together with
our families usually always at my
parents house that's like nice but weird
but nice yeah well mary kate has
recently filed for divorce from my
brother devastated isn't even a strong
enough word to describe how we all feel
it feels like our entire family is going
through the big divorce we were all
blindsided my brother included no one
did anything bad they just weren't meant
to be according to mary kate though i
understand why she wants a divorce i'm
heartbroken i feel like i've lost my
sister and best friend i feel like i'm
losing ashley as well i can't imagine
not seeing ashley's kids grow up and i
can't imagine ashley and mary kate not
seeing my kids grow up or be in my life
we literally talk to each other all day
every day i'm so torn i feel obligated
to my brother to back off from mary kate
and also ashley by association but they
are truly my best friends and my sisters
ashley's kids think that
my parents are their grandparents and my
parents see her kids as their
grandchildren what would you do if you
were in my situation would you continue
your relationship with mary kate and
ashley would you back off for a while i
don't want to hurt my brother's feelings
but i don't want to i don't want to lose
these girls they're my best friends and
support system please help sincerely a
heartbroken sister-in-law
oh my god that's so sad but you know
what the good thing is that your brother
and mary kate still have kids together
so this girl will be in your life
forever yeah and it's so fresh right now
that i think like you should take a step
back just like support your brother but
they'll get to a place where they can
co-parent and you'll all be family and
you'll still do holidays together with
your new spouses because you have kids
together yeah so if your family is as
open and warm as they sound
i think that right now it's awkward and
you should be there for your brother but
in a year's time like i actually think
because they have kids together you guys
will still be seeing each other a lot
and it'll be okay and acceptable for you
to be super close yeah i would say as
long as the divorce proceedings are
going amicably like i don't know why
things have to change that much and just
talk to your brother about it and make
sure that he's okay with that and that
like i think you're the brother it
sounds like it's gonna need time like he
was completely blindsided by her wanting
to get divorced oh
that's what i felt like that he's
heartbroken
not angry but like so it's like okay if
you take a step back to be there for
your brother that will affect your
relationship with mary kate like because
you chose sides and it wasn't hers and
she's your best friend but of course
but maybe one day mary kate gets married
to a new man and that could be like the
brother you never had
no i'm kidding
this is really really hard i would just
i would keep in touch with everyone keep
tabs on everyone make sure your brother
feels supported and i think you can
still talk to mary kate and ashley as
long as things aren't contentious in the
divorce and then you'd have to make a
hard choice yeah but try and keep
everyone together
yeah try and it's on you because you
have put yourself in this position as
being like the sister-in-law of all
sister-in-laws and you know who's having
the last laugh your sister
literally
like so completely unaffected your
actual sister completely unaffected by
this like oh man
you chose strangers yes
literally
oh my god that is so funny um no but
that is quite a pickle like i'm sorry
but you gotta stay with family but do
your best to keep everyone like don't
let it get dark divorce gets dark so
quickly yeah you got like if you want to
keep the family together like you have
you're gonna have to put in the work
it's on you and you're gonna make sure
everyone's communicating that like that
no fight goes festers like
but i think it's worth it because this
family unit that you're describing is so
beautiful and it's also worth it for
mary kate and your brother's kids like
you want them to have like a good and
nothing should change for the kids
really yeah so you can always say like
well the kids have to see each other so
mary kate like let's go get drank yeah i
think it's okay i think you'll it'll get
to it's like bad now but i think in gear
it'll be totally fine yeah as long as
divorce goes well yes i agree so that's
a big issue just monitor the situation
keep tabs on everything keep everyone
together and i think you you can have
your cake and eat it too agreed
thank you to everyone who wrote into
your toasters again if you ever want to
write in it's dear toasters gmail.com
and if you've written us in recently and
have an update for us on how things went
please email us we want to hear from you
deartoasters gmail.com
that's our show
that is our show nobody else's show
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so it's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have radio chess box all
the places where you listen to the
podcast find this morning toast and
leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are and
if you made it to the end of this
episode congratulations um
to let us know that you made it what
emoji should you leave on our most
recent instagram post
maybe
you're so much better at this than i am
i can't yeah okay james corden that's
what i was thinking too lady with chat
give us some give us witchy vibes witchy
vibes in honor of james corden and his
heart feelings bye bye